So it's unit five less than one and we get to talk about
Miracles now as you start to prepare for this week
I don't want you necessarily just thinking about well
I've got approved my students that miracles exists because we're gonna kind of show
a little bit of that
but more so that because there are miracles it
points to the fact that God exists and we start off if you just look at what the
students are gonna study
In their in their Bible say we actually chose first Kings 18 for that very reason
Because when you look at that particular miracle that miracle of Elijah and the
prophets of Baal and a huge fire
They came down and ignited the sacrifice and and how that represented
God's sovereign power in that miracle is just another way
We can see that amongst all the things that Jesus did all the things in the Bible
This is just a really really cool example of how God showed up and performed a
miracle so that we can see
Exactly who God is as students are beginning this week and starting to read through
their intro experience is going to walk them through
What kind of to get them certain to think about miracles and what that looks like so
we asked them specifically like what's the most
improbable event in human history just have them think through like gosh
What would be an improbable event?
So things like it's not likely that if you if I stepped outside right now
I'd probably get struck by lightning probably not going to happen if
I was to walk outside with a meteor just sort of crashed on earth and annihilate me
and everybody around
Probably not gonna happen, but it is an improbable event the same as a miracle
So the intro experience for the students is really to get them thinking through when
we talk about a miracle
What are we talking about?
Because you might get some answers when you start talking with your students
You might actually get some things like well
Is it a miracle that when you're out shopping during Christmas season that a parking
spot?
Right by the door opened up and is it a miracle and a sign from God that you get
this parking maybe
Probably not is that a miracle right?
Is it a miracle when a child is born?
We called the miracle of birth, but is that really a miracle?
We're talking about miracles that we see in scripture
So that's where you want your students to start to think through and get an idea of
what exactly we're talking about
When we're talking about a miracle,
so let's talk for a second about your storyteller
Now it might have been difficult up to this point and it may be difficult moving
forward to find the perfect person
For your storyteller,
you might have had to search high and low and maybe this is one of those spots
You're thinking I really I don't know exactly who I want for a storyteller
For this week, I might suggest they use a student
Find a student that maybe has witnessed a miracle
Maybe a miraculous healing
I once had a student that it was hard to refute because she was such a
Trusted and honest student
So we knew that she was telling the truth and her experience was was was real
But she was on a missions trip in Africa and she was praying over a young a young
girl and this young girls
legs were not the same somehow and
She can't explain it and she she would tell you today that she has no idea
What exactly happened or how it happened,
but she knew some kind of miracle happened, but as they were praying it felt to her
Like this little girls like I grew enough that they were the same and she's and she
told me she's like
Mr. Cosak, I don't know if this is real. I don't know if this is true
But this I feel like this happened and she felt like she was a witness to an actual
miracle a
Little bit like what goes on in scripture now none of us were there and none of us
can verify it
But it was a really fascinating story that helped students see the power of a
miracle because what she thought happened
What she saw happened deeply impacted her and today
She still regularly goes to Africa and serves as a missionary there on an office
Much as she possibly can that that moment deeply impacted her and I'm sure it
impacted a lot of her fellow students
So this is one of those times that it might be really cool to find a student that
maybe not that crazy of a story
But a story nonetheless that that is students of witness to a really divine
Real miracle so as you get ready to engage students in sort of a large group time
I want you to kind of keep one thing in mind that the misconception that we've given
you that science can explain away
Miracles is a very real reality in the life of our students.
They're taught that they're conditioned to
Believe that their condition really for that to be the default like instead of
thinking right away
It's something might be a miracle
if you know
They're conditioned to think that right away something just can be explained by
science and and while there's there should be a
Healthy balance because there's a lot of things that we might think are miracles and
end up being able to be explained
But there's a lot of things that we think we can explain but really end up actually
being a miracle
We really can't explain it as well as we think and science doesn't provide that kind
of explanation science can't explain the supernatural
So be aware as you're preparing your your your lesson to figure out, okay
How do I communicate to students that that miracles can actually happen and the
difference between?
What science can explain and what science cannot explain and it's going to compel
students to start to think about well
Can miracles really happen today and maybe more importantly can miracles happen
right here and right now?
See if you think about you you're probably going to get some some some questions
And this may happen more in your small group time,
but you're going to get some questions
I can almost guarantee that students will start asking well if miracles can happen
How come I don't see miracles happening in my space in my culture my sphere of
influence in my family and those kinds of
Spaces in the same way that we saw miracles in scripture
I mean if you just look at you know the very early stages of acts and Peter and John
walk up to the temple
There's a lame guy standing in front of the city in front of the temple
He can't walk he's never been able to walk and the Bible tells the story of Peter
simply reaches his hand out saying
I don't have any money
But what I have I give you the name of Jesus get up and walk and the guy gets up and
walks and he's
Instantaneously healed and what's fascinating about that story is that this guy has
never been able to walk since birth
Complete muscle atrophy in his legs and all of a sudden his ankles become strong.
He's jumping up and down
He's walking so students are going to ask the question.
Well, how come those miracles don't happen here today?
Well,
they might not happen in your city all that frequently if ever they might not happen
in this country all that often or that frequently or whatever
But we don't know that they don't happen
They might and it's likely that they do happen. Maybe not to that degree
I don't know,
but we can't discount the fact that they think that they just don't have we can't
say they just don't happen
They might happen and God has the power to make that happen if he so chooses
So miracles of a biblical proportion. I would argue are still possible
So while students are in small groups
Encourage your small group leaders to really take time this week to ask maybe pry a
little bit your students to see
Are they really convinced?
Convinced of a couple of things first are they convinced that miracle is or even
possible at all as I even a possibility
And take note of that have your small group leaders actually take note of that
because that's going to become important next week
When we start talking about the resurrection of Jesus are your students convinced
that miracles are at least possible
number two
Are your students convinced that miracles have happened in their midst?
Whether by their friends or by people that they know or have they read things are
they convinced that miracles have actually
Happened so yes,
the first they have to be convinced that they're possible in order to be can be
convinced that they've happened but
Walked them through that process and then
Ask them if they're not convinced
What would it take?
What would it take to help them see the probability and the possibility of miracles
all around them?
Then do they have to open up their view of God?
Do they have to just open up their view of who Jesus is and what the cross is all
about we'll get to that next week
What has to happen for them?
Do they think in order to make miracles a reality in their mind so that they can
even see some things that God is up to?
One thing to keep in mind as you're navigating through this although we're we talk a
lot about the fact that miracles are
Possible and they're verifiable and that they do happen and we see throughout
scripture that God works in mighty ways
And we we want to boast that miracles happen all throughout the world
But this can also be a very very personal thing
Miracles can bring up really really important
Questions in the lives of our students
How come God performed a miracle and in this person's life, but not in my life
How come God healed this person, but not this person?
It almost feels like God is picking and choosing how does that work and how do you
walk through?
Walk with students through difficult times like that and I'm gonna be honest with
you
There's really not a specific answer that I can give you that well God does this
because it's not there
But your job as a leader is to walk alongside and help your students in their
specific situations
Navigate those particular circumstances in those particular
Parts of their lives so that they grow closer to Christ not further